Today I want to talk about,
uh,
about Stalin is,
and in doing so,
you know,
15 years ago,
uh,
lots of what we now know about the Soviet Union,
and it's through its entire history.
We,
we didn't,
we,
we didn't know because the archives weren't open.
And when the,
when the Soviet Union collapsed,
uh,
fell apart,
a disintegrated I in the early 1990s,
gradually lots of the archives are open.
And so,
uh,
um,
what I have to say today,
I don't work in the Soviet Union,
but draws upon the work of Michael Holquist.
Uh,
I'm not Michael Holquist.
That's it.
That's his dad of a guy.
What a tease.
I can't,
uh,
have,
Holquist anyone who used to teach at Cordell and now teaches it at,
at,
uh,
Princeton,
and,
um,
you know,
and,
and work also a more recent work on stolen ism of by Sheila Fitzpatrick.
So,
um,
let me just lay out the,
you know,
the overview at the,
at the beginning,
and I sit around this morning.
I didn't get home till real late last night,
so I sent her,
I sent along about 1230 in the morning.
Uh,
various terms,
what I forgot a couple,
a democratic centralism,
right.
Opposition and blue.
Caren.
Uh,
and what these,
this,
this stuff's all in the book,
so I hope you're able to get that and I'll do the same for next time.
Um,
so the,
you know,
the question remains is,
is,
did,
did Lennon,
did Lennon inevitably lead to Stalin and,
and that's,
that's,
uh,
you know,
that,
that's a hard one.
Uh,
I,
I guess,
uh,
um,
you know,
basically the structure of,
uh,
what became a morphed into the Soviet regime,
was set it the way that the Bolshevik party operated even before taking power
and a fundamental concept was democratic.
Centralism.
Uh,
and that is,
uh,
it's the way that the Soviet state became,
became organized.
It's a top down,
uh,
way of,
of,
uh,
of making decisions and,
and,
and sending out a relevant communication.
In principle.
It was supposed to,
uh,
involve the debate,
at the highest levels.
And then,
then once decisions were taken that then they were,
uh,
communicated,
through,
uh,
the communist party.
But of course,
uh,
the cheer,
the paranoia of,
of,
of Stalin,
and he wasn't,
you know,
as a clinical paranoid,
uh,
and this paranoia,
led to the deaths of,
of,
of millions of people.
But debate itself became as a concept under stalling ism,
ah,
uh,
identified with anti-soviet behavior.
And,
and so,
essentially what had been begun as,
as,
as a,
as a popular revolution on behalf of the,
uh,
of,
of working people and also to an extent on behalf of nationalities,
uh,
became the dictatorship,
not of the proletariat,
but of the Communist Party of the Bolshevik Party,
transformed into the communist party and the dictatorship of,
um,
uh,
of Stalin.
Uh,
and of course,
as his paranoia,
I increased,
uh,
the purchase,
the purchase followed,
uh,
the big show trials,
some of which were,
uh,
people,
western Communist went and,
and sat and listened to it to hear people confessed to having been in,
in a,
a cahoots with,
with,
uh,
with Nazis or with,
with,
uh,
with the English royalists or whomever,
and confessed to things that they certainly never done,
uh,
not long before,
their,
their execution.
Uh,
and so one of the points to be made today a is in a following,
I'm following Holquist,
um,
is that the,
the structure of,
of the Stalinist terror,
um,
there were antecedents that one could see in,
uh,
in the civil war,
and in the period of,
uh,
of Lennon's,
dot domination of,
in the early years of,
uh,
of the Soviet Union.
Uh,
but that very quickly,
very early on,
um,
that the people who imagine that nationalities,
uh,
would have,
would have autonomy.
Uh,
the,
those,
those hopes were,
were destroyed quite quickly and installing,
they had been,
you know,
a minister or whatever they called her comment,
call me,
Sarah,
of,
of nationalities.
Uh,
and the idea that workers,
self management,
self control,
control the means of production,
uh,
wha what would be implemented in this new brave world,
were shattered rather quickly,
uh,
with,
with strikes and,
and,
and protest by,
by workers,
uh,
a smashed by a,
by,
by the police,
uh,
by,
by the Soviet state.
Um,
and of course the illusion would,
would be perpetuated in the,
you know,
in the 20s,
and,
and even in the 30s,
that this was a,
a true,
uh,
a worker's paradise and that everything was groovy,
groovy.
But the talk was always about the radiant future.
And the radiant was a word that they used a lot,
that the future,
and I'll talk more about this in awhile,
uh,
would be radiant.
It would be glorious,
but the sacrifices had to be made now,
and they had to be made now to protect the revolution against the,
uh,
against the Americans,
against the,
uh,
the French and against the British and the powers of capitalism,
it,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and of course,
as you all know,
it,
uh,
it never,
it never came to be.
And that,
that's the tragedy of,
uh,
of the,
of the restroom revolution.
Um,
well,
any more about this?
Uh,
um,
I,
uh,
yeah,
in a while.
Um,
but certainly first of all was backdrop I to all of this,
uh,
one,
um,
because of the civil war and because of the of famine conditions and because of
just enormous economic,
uh,
a hardship,
the,
uh,
trying to,
to,
trying to have a state what was,
was not,
uh,
it was not clear how this,
who could,
could this possibly,
uh,
a be done.
Uh,
and,
and you've got a country with all these nationalities and,
and which is basically a,
still,
essentially a country of peasants despite the industrial work in the Ural
Mountains.
And,
and,
uh,
in the mines and in,
in,
um,
uh,
in what town it became Petrograd became Leonard Grad,
obviously later.
Uh,
so you're going to how to,
how to do this and,
and,
uh,
the war itself,
as in all of the countries that participated in world one had to,
had just had done an enormous ravages.
I mean,
the Germans are fighting,
uh,
inside,
inside Russia and the subsequent civil war,
uh,
of that,
you know,
decimated large parts of,
of,
of the countryside a left the country,
uh,
barely able to function between 1921 and 1922 or in 1921 and 1922,
this is in what you're reading.
Um,
more than 7 million people died of starvation a and sickness,
uh,
during that period.
And remember the wars go on.
The war against Poland goes on until finally the situation is resolved with the
Treaty of,
of Riga in 1921,
which I don't think it's a is in,
in your book.
Um,
but,
but Lenin implemented the new economic policy and,
um,
as,
as he and the other,
uh,
Soviet leaders,
grappled with,
uh,
with a country and virtual a collapse.
Um,
he recognized,
uh,
that,
that the ideology of communism,
uh,
which,
called for the abolition of private a property private ownership,
uh,
and the destruction of the free market would have to be sacrificed,
for,
uh,
the future because you simply had to be able to,
to feed people.
You had to have peasants not hoarding what they produced,
uh,
or waiting for higher prices.
I,
you needed to have a free market system,
uh,
at least for Hawaiian [inaudible],
because of,
of,
um,
uh,
the fact that,
that,
that people,
people resisted what n w which was what was called war communism.
Uh,
which was,
uh,
sort of,
a shock communists therapy that I had proved not to really work at all.
And so the new economic policy is,
uh,
is promulgated in,
in March of 19,
uh,
21 in and the features you can,
you can read about,
but basically,
uh,
the state remains.
It's,
it maintains it's centralized control over the economy under still centralized
planning,
but that,
but the NDP allowed peasants to,
uh,
to use their land as if it was their own.
And,
and,
and largely,
uh,
in most cases,
it's still,
uh,
was and allowed a markets to a lot of them to market their products and sell
them at a market,
a market prices in order to get food on,
uh,
food to people who,
who,
who needed it.
Uh,
otherwise they too would,
would've died.
Um,
and the state can maintain its control over over heavy industry,
but this is all going to be just a small,
uh,
a retreat along,
the road to socialism.
Now it's succeeded,
it succeeded,
it works.
Um,
and gradually,
uh,
the production of,
of,
of food,
uh,
reach a prewar a levels and,
and small scale industrial production,
uh,
revives now,
oh,
another,
a name I should have written on the board.
Of course I was so tired.
Uh,
and I,
and I did all this last night is of course coolmax.
Um,
and so two groups of people who profited during this period,
two groups of people,
uh,
would,
um,
in the long memory of the communist leadership,
uh,
get theirs,
during,
uh,
the five year plan.
The first are those people who,
for example,
were,
were small merchants,
uh,
or not in,
in size,
but,
but the,
you know,
they,
uh,
sold products on a,
I'm the free market and did very well during this period of,
of,
uh,
of the new economic policy.
And they became known as neck men.
Nap is the new economic policy.
And the net men were people who did well during this period and the other,
and it's a term as we'll see in a while that became a,
you know,
a term of denigration and indeed would,
could lead you straight to the gulag.
Uh,
if you were lucky.
and we're an executed before that.
And these were cooler box and cooler box.
Basically,
we're prosperous peasants.
They were well off peasants.
And during the period of the new economic policy,
the cool box people with land who had something to sell and it did well indeed,
uh,
because they're,
they're goods,
a fetch fetch,
good prices,
and they did very well.
Uh,
but with,
uh,
you know,
with the gradual ending of new economic policy,
which will trickles to an end,
uh,
you know,
after,
after Lennon,
uh,
that they would become targets,
in the mass collectivization campaign,
uh,
that accompanied the five year plan that is 1928 to 1933.
Um,
and,
uh,
would be themselves victims,
of the purges,
uh,
as we'll see.
And of course,
well,
one of the great tragedies,
a,
I mean,
the tragedy of,
of,
of the Russian revolution.
I mean,
there's a quote in there,
uh,
from,
I guess if somebody in the Red Army who says that we've,
did we do all this?
Did we fight in the civil war?
Did we try to save the revolution against some really basically horrible,
uh,
legions and,
and the white armies,
uh,
during the civil war,
we save the revolution in order to round up cool locks and put them in,
in the middle of a field,
uh,
in line them up,
in the middle of a field and gunned them down with machine guns to kill them.
Did we do all of this to,
uh,
to eliminate from the face of the earth?
These people who had,
uh,
you know,
a bit,
despite being relatively privileged,
uh,
had,
had struggled and had managed to survive the whole thing.
And,
you know,
sadly,
the answer is yes.
I mean,
it,
it came to that.
And,
and the,
uh,
the question is,
to what extent was this automatically built with this part of the system from
the beginning?
And I'll give you some examples that Holquist sites in a minute.
And he says,
you can see this coming.
If you look at the first,
uh,
Eh,
the first years of,
um,
uh,
of the,
of,
of the Soviet people.
Let me give you some,
uh,
some examples of this.
Um,
and this,
this is,
you know,
before,
uh,
the period where we're Stalin,
Stalin,
Stalin becomes a successor.
I mean,
Stalin,
Stalin worked very hard to make it seem,
uh,
as,
as Lennon with was,
uh,
was,
he'd had,
he had,
uh,
one stroke and then another,
and Stalin tried to keep access,
uh,
a closed,
to other people.
And,
uh,
he,
he worked feverish to make it seem that,
that Stalin was the chosen successor of,
uh,
of Lennon.
And there some famous doctrine photographs where we're,
uh,
stolen,
has a,
has had himself inserted,
uh,
next to Lenin in fee and famous opposes of Lennon.
Uh,
who was,
uh,
who was a pretty good speaker and nothing like Trotsky.
Trotsky was young.
[inaudible] has,
was the greatest order of,
of the entire period.
Uh,
but,
but Lennon wasn't too bad.
Uh,
and,
and them literally himself stuck into o two,
two pictures where he would be there.
Uh,
and he also took some of Lennon's writings and sort of,
uh,
you know,
quote unquote updated them with,
with,
with his,
uh,
to me it seem light,
light,
light.
Like he,
he the mantle,
I was there and everybody is,
everybody knows,
I mean,
who falls his stuff at all,
uh,
that,
that Lennon was,
was,
was in his final days,
most concerned that the Comrade Stalin,
uh,
with that,
his leadership Wa was potentially very dangerous.
Uh,
I,
and,
and he,
you know,
he,
he expressed that those fears in a,
you know,
in,
in the letter,
if I remember correctly,
you know,
written with a very shaky hand of a man who had,
who had had a stroke,
a,
uh,
a very serious stroke,
and then who was close to death,
uh,
that,
that he,
uh,
he had his doubts about,
about Comrade Stalin.
Uh,
not exactly from it from the beginning.
And also it's important to note that the Trotsky,
uh,
who,
who am I,
as I said the other day,
would,
would finally be tracked down and,
and,
uh,
assassinated in a garden in Mexico City.
Uh,
or that,
that the differences between Trotsky and Stalin,
of course,
uh,
they went beyond etiology.
Trotsky was w in what became known as the left opposition,
uh,
there was pushing for,
for more,
you know,
active instigation of,
of revolutions in other places.
And,
and ironically was pushing even more for,
uh,
you know,
for collectivization,
uh,
even early on,
but it went,
it wasn't more than,
uh,
than that.
I mean,
there was a,
there was a rivalry between two men who both were extraordinarily sure of
themselves,
uh,
and who thought that they were,
um,
uh,
that they were the person who should lead a first save and then lead the,
the,
the Soviet Union.
And of course,
Trotsky's role in,
in,
uh,
the Red Army,
as a strategist with was,
it was extremely important,
but there was more than that also,
uh,
there was,
more than a small trace of,
of,
uh,
of antisemitism,
in,
in installing [inaudible] and when he would refer to refer to,
you know,
cosmopolitan to enemies and things like that.
And cosmopolitanism was sort of a code word for,
for,
for Jews,
uh,
for,
for Jewish,
uh,
people within the party.
And they're more than that.
There was more than that for that,
but a trust gave courses is a,
um,
is expelled from the party.
And,
and finally as tracked down,
uh,
and killed.
And,
and,
and some of these,
as you know from reading Orwell,
uh,
some of these,
you know,
these factions in these differences play themselves out and this anticipation
and World War II,
that was the Spanish civil war and the Troskey serve very,
very important faction in,
in the,
uh,
in,
in the Spanish civil war.
And of course,
as you know from reading Orwell,
the role of the,
of the solidness,
uh,
in all of this.
Um,
anyway,
um,
just a few things before I,
I,
um,
turned to Holquist argument about how some of this,
you can see some of the horrors coming early on.
Let me just define a,
um,
uh,
a style aneurysm,
you know,
as a,
as a term.
And here I'm drawing on,
on,
um,
on Holquist ah,
that is a set of tenets,
policies and practices that characterize the Soviet government.
You know,
during the period when Stalin is in power and it's taller than this,
some last and still stolen,
finally dies.
One is,
uh,
19,
53.
Yeah,
that is when,
when Stalin dies.
Um,
and the beginning of the,
the five year plan a that is 1928 to 1933,
uh,
is really,
the real beginning of a,
of a stall.
I'm this,
I'm that you can anticipate some of this as we'll see in a minute.
Um,
and I'm installing with them is,
uh,
does not only takes a sort of democratic centralism of decision making,
but what it does is it employs a state coercion.
And we're more than this state terror,
uh,
with the goal of transforming this still relatively backward a society into Ah,
a Soviet state that could sustain itself,
that could be old heavy industries.
And this was the obsession of stolen and stolen is that heavy industries would
have to be built and that they would be built on the backs of the peasantry who
would lose their land and become industrial workers.
There's a massive urbanization as we'll see,
uh,
in the Soviet Union,
during this period.
And the obvious central characteristics of Stalin is as you've already seen,
or the abolition of private property,
first of all,
and the end of,
of free trade,
the end of the market,
the market is to disappear.
And if you're abolishing private property in a vast,
vast state in which you know,
two generations before,
you still had serfs,
what you want to do from their point of view with collectivize agriculture.
Yeah.
The collect the massive collectivization of agriculture.
And this would as you know,
become a characteristic of,
of the satellite states,
ah,
in eastern Europe and the eastern central Europe with varying degrees and
varying degrees,
uh,
in,
those states.
But the economy is planned.
It's run in a centralized fashion and predicated upon mass industries,
rapid industrialization.
And part of this with the liquidation,
not a nice word of those exploiting classes.
Okay.
That is the bourgeois.
The NAP men,
the Kulaks,
the aristocrats and the clergy.
And so this involves,
uh,
the porting people to the gulags or them wherever they were,
incarcerating them in the Google lines and the purge,
the tear,
the political tear against no alleged enemies,
including those who disagreed with Stalin within,
uh,
within the leadership of the,
of the Soviet Union.
Thus the purchase that you can read about of the left opposition of a is Enovia
Evan Trotsky and Bucara wins,
right?
Opposition.
And with this comes the cult of personality.
Okay.
That Stalin himself becomes,
uh,
and I say this,
you know,
in quotes,
a czar like figure
yeah.
Are,
there are still truck drivers in,
in Russia who have pictures of Stalin and know in their trucks and other other
people as well.
And of course,
this leads to obviously to kind of move a half bake a political sign.
Yes.
Interpretations that,
well,
you ha you have a Zuora state,
you have an autocracy and inevitably becomes another,
uh,
autocracy with a czar like figure,
the cult of personality of stolen.
But you think of,
of Mao's China and they're,
you know,
the cult of personality.
If anything,
you know,
what was,
what was even more than that with the Little Red Book and,
and,
and all of this business.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the drew repeat the obvious that,
that,
that the Soviet Union was the dictatorship of the communist party
and the dictatorship of the communist party with a dictatorship of Joseph
Stalin.
Okay.
And the paranoia of Joseph Stalin now,
ironically,
uh,
stolen is,
I'm sure,
you know,
was not rush them.
Yeah.
Even though the empire was largely run the Soviet Empire,
and it was,
that was largely run in the interests of Russia and Russians.
Stalin was a George,
and he was from,
you know,
from the country,
uh,
in which all of,
you know,
these,
these things have happened.
And,
and just the last,
you know,
five or six months,
he started out as a seminary student.
He was expelled for Reading Marxists tracks.
Uh,
like a lot of these people,
he took aliases because he,
oh,
he robbed banks to money for the,
uh,
for,
the Bolshevik party.
Uh,
the Stalin a means in Russian man of steel.
That was his alias.
That wasn't his,
his original name.
Uh,
and,
and he was,
he was,
became the a,
and he's a Georgian,
remember I just said he becomes the administer or the comedy cellar of
nationalities,
but determined to,
to,
to snap the head off of,
of the hydro,
of,
of the,
of the danger of,
of nationalists a revival in,
in the states because p is communism in theory was antithetical to,
uh,
to nationalism.
Though,
ironically,
as you all know,
I mean,
they did that,
it doesn't really work that way.
And there were,
you know,
there were strongly nationalists Communist,
uh,
states that still retained a hungry,
for example,
uh,
or,
or check Tekla Slovakia for example.
There were that retained even within the satellite nature,
uh,
kind of,
pride in,
in,
in trying to make it work.
Even in 1968,
his Dube checked in 1968 before the tanks roll into prog,
tries to making the,
uh,
tries to make a acumen,
faced,
uh,
socialism with,
with,
with a Chieko checkins and Slovak face.
But of course,
it,
it doesn't,
um,
it doesn't work now.
I mean,
through the whole period,
as everybody knows,
I mean,
they execute,
uh,
millions of people.
I mean,
in World War Two,
uh,
the figures of the number of,
of Soviets who died in World War II,
who was about 25 million,
25 million people.
Now,
if you're thinking about styling Grad,
and you're thinking about the siege of Leningrad,
which,
you know,
goes on and on and on and takes a,
a million lives,
uh,
but within that 25 million,
lots of those people were people who died,
who died in the gulags.
Uh,
uh,
they did not die from reasons the war,
they died.
They died in the goop gulags and many of them were executed for,
for being a Kulak or being a Netmon or w w you know,
or whatever.
Now,
can you see this coming?
Can you,
can one see this coming just a couple of points along the way?
Um,
that during World War One states had increased their power,
their ability to control what became sort of command economies.
Uh,
to mobilize the resources of the state.
in Russia,
in World War One,
the imperial government,
uh,
Holquist,
rights initiated a,
a deportation of quote unquote the Jewish element.
Now remember the,
the,
the rabidly antisemitism of,
of,
of the czar and Alexandra on the border lines as quote,
pernicious quote,
harmful and dangerous to the Russian people.
Um,
and thus,
uh,
that's in war time.
They are,
uh,
they just as an Ra in Italy,
Italy went to war in part so that they had the idea that they could somehow make
citizens Italian field themselves.
Italian.
There is this nature is the worst being flood in Russia,
uh,
that you,
that you will increase the Russian,
this of the effort of the empire,
even though all these other nationalities are involved by excluding people,
by excluding people.
Now they're not excluding people,
uh,
by,
you know,
putting them up the wall.
I'm shooting them.
Uh,
but they,
uh,
there nonetheless,
there,
um,
uh,
the,
the language is somewhat there.
Uh,
for example,
the,
they described the whites who are a nasty group,
uh,
many of them and just nasty bloodthirsty group.
Not all of them,
but many of them,
uh,
they described,
um,
eh,
the,
the Jews as,
as,
uh,
as microbes.
This is the whites describing the Jews as microbes.
Uh,
uh,
and,
and Bolshevism is a social disease.
I mean,
the kind of disease metaphors,
uh,
are the next step is if you have it,
you know,
a disease.
If you have a cancer,
you cut it out,
you exclude it by cutting it out.
And so the language of exclusion,
uh,
is,
is already there.
Um,
and at one point,
the Soviets in the very first part of the,
of the,
of the Soviet Union began a problem with program,
what they call d causes constant causation.
They want to remove an entire caustic population,
which they viewed as,
as potentially disloyal to the revolution.
But you can't,
you can't do that.
And you know what I mean?
It's just too hard to do that when all these other things are going on until
they don't really,
um,
uh,
they,
they can't do that.
But in the early years,
the Lennon years,
they're still,
you find these things in 1921,
there's a campaign against bandit TISM that is bandits are people who,
who don't support the,
uh,
the communists.
That term is often used by the way in,
in,
uh,
you know,
in France under Vishi that their terror,
that people,
the resistors are bandits are there or they're terrorists,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And band has become a dangerous epidemic.
Again,
the disease metaphor,
they're dangerous because,
because they are in 1920,
Stalin informed Trotsky,
a Holquist found,
uh,
that an order would soon come directing quote to total extermination of the
white officer course,
a core,
uh,
of course,
total extermination.
That's pretty strong language.
That's not just simply putting people in,
in the,
you know,
in jail or in a camp,
in a reeducation camp that is,
you know,
getting rid of them.
They create camps,
which were called filter spaces where people could be kept until they had seen
the light,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and,
uh,
they,
they have all these white guard prison.
Uh,
what these white prisoners that,
that,
that some of whom of course executed.
And the checker or the police who oversee all of this.
I mean,
that's an obvious term.
Uh,
so examples from the,
from the civil war as Holquist and hocus words Holquist words show the project
of fashioning society by excising particular elements was an intrinsic,
intrinsic aspect of Soviet power from the very beginning.
But it's not on the scale that would come later.
Um,
there are lists of people drawn up in,
in the,
uh,
early 1920s that would be used in 1937 and 1938 during,
the great,
um,
uh,
I the great purge.
Uh,
and so when,
you know,
when the campaigns of collectivization,
which are bloody,
which are massacres come along,
um,
you know,
the Deq Kulik cool accusation campaign,
get rid of the cool ox 1929,
1930,
uh,
it becomes,
on a more urgent and more paranoid scale a memorandum.
This is the kind of stuff that we now know from the archives,
a memorandum from March 15th,
1931 states that with regard to the cooler box,
the goal of deportation from all regions was quote too,
totally cleanse them of cool ox and,
and another a slightly earlier in February called for them to be quote
immediately liquidated.
Uh,
we will exile the Kulak by thousands and when necessary,
shoot the Kulak breed.
We will make soap of the cooler box.
Our class enemy must be wiped off from the face of the earth.
Strong language.
And thus in 1930 more than yeah,
20,000 cool.
Ox were sentenced to death.
And of course,
many more are gunned down when they protest and they protest,
they,
they killed her animals rather than turn them off,
uh,
over,
to,
uh,
did the call me Sal,
they,
uh,
they burn their harvest,
they burn their farms.
Uh,
they are,
these are weapons and the weapons of the weak is my dear friend Jim Scott.
What w and political science department,
uh,
would,
would call it,
and we can,
the,
they were,
because they're confronting these enormous,
uh,
these enormous military forces,
but they fight back,
you know,
they fight back and they,
they don't just,
uh,
they just don't go down in,
in a,
you know,
and,
uh,
you know,
in,
in a heat with,
with,
without fighting.
Now,
one of the interesting things,
interesting things about this is just after,
you know,
one of the,
one of the key trends in the end of the 19th century is of course the origins of
sociology.
Uh,
intellectual trends.
The idea of,
of counting and figuring and thinking about Contemporary Society,
uh,
you know,
Max Faber and,
and,
and all that.
I mean,
really important important stuff,
positivism,
uh,
all of this.
And so,
um,
that's kind of censuses the developed way before all of this.
I mean,
the first sense is I said in France,
the first really accurate one outside of municipal ones is an in 1841.
But what they do is,
is they,
um,
they use sort of modern tools,
uh,
of censuses,
surveys and questionnaires to get information on the entire population.
And you better be damn careful when you write down who you are on one of these
forms.
When they say,
who is your grandfather?
What did your grandfather do?
You know,
what,
what are you going to write?
You can't write down.
He was that he was a industrial worker.
If you wasn't,
uh,
what,
what if he's a Kulak?
What if he's a noble?
What if he's an Orthodox priest?
Well,
you're guilty by association,
even another once a Kulak once a clergyman,
once an aristocrat buy class identity,
you are guilty.
You are guilty.
Uh,
and uh,
they use the censuses of 1926 in 1937 and the last one before the war of 1939 as
a way of deciding who should get passports and who shouldn't get passports
and who should be be sent off,
uh,
to,
wherever.
And so they're beginning the,
by 19,
uh,
by 1934,
27 million people in the Soviet Union had been monitored.
And given state ID cards.
Now the French who had to have an ID card also to go from one department mall to
the next,
to go from a,
to go from Massey to to a nice,
you had to have a passport and internal passport.
But what they do,
you know,
it's the same state thrust,
uh,
except that it has a murderer's outcome because of you're classifying people.
If you're counting people,
if you're registering people,
this is way before the quiet violence of the computer.
If we show up her whole memory memorably,
put it,
uh,
the,
but the outcome is,
is very different.
And they use archivist,
some of,
I have friends who are archivists and they're not going to be doing this kind of
thing.
And these are French archivists and,
and uh,
um,
uh,
but they're using archivists who I,
again,
I mean there are fearful for their life.
I mean,
you're an archivist,
you're a middleclass,
you're an archivist with,
with writing and reading skills,
and you're potentially an enemy of the state because you're from the wrong
social class.
And so they say,
we want you to,
you know,
we want to want to look at your archives.
We want you to find out who's in what category in your region.
And you better do it.
And archivists in [inaudible] in 1939,
coordinator Holquist identify 108,000 enemies of the people.
And once you're classified as an enemy of the people,
baby,
you're toast.
That's it.
You're toast.
Now,
Sheila Fitzpatrick is a wonderful,
a wonderful historian.
Um,
was one of the first to,
to,
to study what she calls the extraordinarily extraordinary everydayness of,
of Stalin Islam.
What was life like in a place where the only way of getting anything and
potentially the only way of surviving is your relationship to a bureaucratic
figure.
Because Stalin is the essence of state collectivization of state.
Totalitarianism is you have to have this enormous bureaucracy and it's the
bureaucracy that calls,
uh,
that calls,
of the shots.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's the,
the,
the problem,
well,
let me,
let me put some of the,
some of the points that are important
in getting buy.
Who are apt to be the militants in all of this,
who are apt to be the true believers in all of this,
the most loyal to the project of creating this new world,
this new world that never came.
The answer is young people,
younger people,
uh,
that there were many cases,
of course,
of younger people denouncing their parents,
be asked to denounce their parents,
but the most militant and the most faithful where people who had not,
who in the 1930 [inaudible] for example,
if they were 25 years old,
they didn't really remember the old regime.
They didn't remember the czarist autocracy.
And they are more,
more likely to think that there's nothing wrong with trying to decide who still
has religious icons on their walls,
whose parents,
uh,
religiously went to church.
Uh,
and so the young people were more apt to be,
uh,
after be the militants in all of this.
And if you were a militant,
what you did was you denounced class enemies,
these cool ox and the priests,
members of the pre-revolutionary,
a nobility,
former capitalists.
But again,
once a capitalist,
you are always a capitalist.
Once a Kulak you are always a cooler.
Um,
and people who had be been declared as non toilers,
that is not people who are not,
not really workers or really peasants who are cool ox.
They are deprived of the vote,
not that elections subsequently men and anything in the Soviet Union as early as
the constitution of 19,
uh,
18th.
And so these young Milt militants,
uh,
undertake a war on,
on bourgeois specialists.
Now,
one of the problems of course,
with,
with the,
uh,
this is the campaign for rapid industrialization is they're really torn because
you need these bourgeois specialists because they're technocrats and they're the
ones that have to keep up the production a tall,
I mean,
the production count,
they have to keep it up there.
But then you go into this period,
you'd say,
well,
you can't have a bunch of bourgeois specialists who are educated.
And so those people get liquidated,
maybe not killed,
but,
but get,
get removed and then they will bring in and replace them with.
Sometimes peasants would absolutely no education,
which is not their fault at all.
The Soviets do educate people in this period.
Uh,
there's a huge increase in literacy in this period,
but they're turning over important management positions within the Soviet Union
in this push for rapid industrialization that people that can't read,
right.
Uh,
and uh,
really,
you know,
just don't have the kind of,
uh,
financial,
that kind of ability to,
to do it.
And then of course,
that causes all sorts of,
uh,
all sorts of problems.
Um,
and of course,
uh,
the bureaucracies and Kruth increasingly filled with people who are not
competent,
uh,
but are there because of their party loyalty.
And if you weren't loyal to the party,
uh,
there was nowhere.
I know where you're going to go.
How does this affect ordinary Soviet citizens,
whether it's constant propaganda?
Talk about the radiant future and enormous sacrifices now will be worth it in
the end.
I mean,
Mark's,
after all said,
this been cited scientific socialism.
It's going to take a long time.
Thus,
uh,
the,
if you see these,
and I've been in the Moscow subway,
well been a long time ago,
but he sort of heroic murals of,
of the,
of,
uh,
of the Soviet worker,
the,
uh,
stack overnight.
I mean,
don't write it down,
but this time I think he said the book,
but status that this guy stack Hoven off was a guy or whatever his name was,
who,
uh,
had apparently you'll set a world record by extracting the most coal any human
had ever done.
And of course it was basically made up and he became this kind of image of hard
work.
But I'll tell you,
if you go to,
if you go to a lot of this are art deco murals into,
in Detroit,
Michigan.
And the kind,
or for example,
I'm,
I'm not making this as an analogy,
but,
but there was an equivalent under national socialism also the idea of the,
of the German worker,
you know,
toiling away and all that with the interests of the state.
But basically it's,
um,
the idea that,
that,
that Russia could be moved by hard work out of backwardness,
toward this radiant future.
It does keep people,
it does keep people going.
There's always this contrast between then the old days,
the battle days when these folks ruled the net men and the cooler box and the
Aristotle aristocracy and all of that.
Uh,
and the,
the,
the inevitable,
uh,
a future that's the landlords were gone.
There's collective ownership of the means of production.
Uh,
so everything has got to be okay.
The motto is the Party is always right.
Uh,
and you better believe it.
Um,
and,
and the state shaped the way,
uh,
people,
a lift.
Now a part of it,
of course.
I mean,
those people lived through the purge.
there's just,
well,
I'll tell you a story.
Um,
I had this colleague along long time ago when I first came here,
who grew up in Moscow in the 1930s because his father was the Persian ambassador
to Moscow.
And this was the,
you know,
and the purchase people were announcing their parents and things like that.
People were being taken away in the night and there were boots in the hall and
it was a pretty damn scary time to live.
And one day he was in this big school,
he was in [inaudible],
which is a middle school,
so he's 12 years old basically.
And he is sitting in one of these big buildings there and the bell rings,
you go from one class to the next class and the bell rang and the guy who's
sitting in front of him,
12 year old boy gets up,
he puts his car,
Tabu down,
his,
his book carrier down and he goes out there on the fifth floor.
He goes to the stairwell and he jumps over to his death just like that.
He stepped over.
The thing fell.
If you're 12 years old,
you're gonna remember that kind of thing.
Uh,
he didn't really know because you didn't discuss such things,
whether he had announced his parents and felt badly about it,
whether it's parents had been taken away,
he didn't have any idea where they were.
Uh,
but this was,
this was one of the tragedies also.
Uh,
and a lot of it is,
you know,
of course a lot of it is self deception and these were very work very for very
poor people.
And you believe in the radiant future because this is a very,
very poor place.
And you saw these stolen skyscrapers raising a,
there's a big debate in Warsaw,
whether the one that's there should be kept and you saw more literacy and you
saw sometimes products on the market,
but the deception was there.
They'll greats hopes were there.
The reality was completely different.
You would have bizarre things happen suddenly.
I mean,
you have state planning.
So for awhile there were all these sort of red female stockings were on the
market because that was supposed to be cool.
And you had a lot of western visitors who had seen the same female,
uh,
red stockings,
which were very much in,
in Paris and Berlin,
but this wasn't Paris and Berlin,
this,
this was Moscow.
So suddenly you have a lot of that.
Someone's thought,
well,
ketchup look good to the outsiders when they come.
And so they start producing ketchup.
There's nothing to put the ketchup on.
And the most ridiculous example I've ever heard is that they start producing
lots of bathtubs because you know,
people are waiting line to get apartments,
which is true until 1992,
uh,
they're waiting line to get,
depart,
get apartments.
Uh,
though things got a lot better.
I,
you know,
after World War Two,
but still,
uh,
and so the,
if you're going to have an apartment that's,
that is a progress.
The radiant future,
you've gotta have a bathtub.
So they produce all these bathtubs,
but they forget to produce corks,
uh,
or stoppers.
So for a long time you had people that were lucky enough to have bath tubs,
but the water just runs out.
Uh,
and they could show them off to their friends.
but it,
it just,
you know,
it's definitely doesn't work,
but there is the illusion,
and I'm going to have to end with this because I went to long earlier,
there's more to say,
but there's always more to say.
There was the illusion and there were lots of true believers,
uh,
and,
and people who also wanted to radiant future and who,
you know,
I mean,
the 1960s,
we were also late,
1960s,
please,
not the early ones.
And,
and the,
the 70s we were all dealing with,
with,
you know,
our radiology of,
of the week.
And I had an uncle who made a great deal to me,
uh,
who was a communist and he was,
he was trained in Berlin as a psychoanalyst.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
you know,
he worked for,
for both Pharma,
which is the,
the paper.
And he claimed to have known Demetrius [inaudible],
who was an important,
uh,
a communist.
And he was a true believer and I,
and he was a true believer always at the end of his life.
He ended up passing.
We're heading,
his wife passed the save the whale petitions and,
and,
uh,
he was no longer a communist.
But I remember when I was a little boy,
him telling me that people trying to escape from communist communism were
psychotic.
Uh,
the people trying to get over the wall and Berlin were psychotic for trying to
leave this radiant future of a worker's Paradise.
And there were a lot of true believers.
Uh,
and they,
these people,
a lot of them,
and I'm not dissing my uncle,
who I love deeply and who met a great deal on my life.
Um,
and,
and especially my aunt,
but you know,
they,
they believed in,
people would go to the show trials and they will,
they would see people saying,
yes,
I was in cahoots with,
with,
uh,
you know,
a Romanian fascist or with a Dutch,
a Dutch fascist,
or with,
uh,
Georgia nationalist or something like that.
And they would admit to all sorts of things,
possibly hoping was going to save their life.
And it didn't,
it never did.
And they were executed,
uh,
install an,
executed the mall.
He executed the entire general staff practically of the army.
And one of the most amazing things about the,
the second world wars,
how the Red Army,
how they not only survive but one and retraining people.
There weren't any admirals left or one.
There was nobody laughed.
They'd keep killed them all.
He'd killed them all and it,
but people continue to believe they th they believed in.
And the whole idea,
the whole phrase maybe you've heard of is,
uh,
the phrase the Potemkin village.
And I guess that's a good place to end up Potemkin village.
If for example,
if you're watching an old TV western and you see a facade that you know,
get the bar and you've got Miss Kitty and you've got,
you know,
all of this and a few people,
punching each other out,
there's nothing behind it.
It's just all a fraud.
It's nothing.
And they would bring these visitors from the West in this brave new industrial
world.
And they see,
they see,
they see parts of towns that had been reshaped and they'd meet,
met the first,
they meet the first liver at people in a family.
And they were,
it was very competitive,
was very true.
I mean,
some good things happen too,
but,
uh,
they were far outweighed by,
by the bad things.
But a Potemkin village would be,
you'd go and you'd,
you'd see this facade and you'd be whisked through.
And this is where the,
the children's railroad will be.
uh,
you know,
the kindergarten is going to be,
it's always,
they're going to be,
and it never happened.
And that,
I suppose it's the tragedy of the Russian,
a revolution,
arguably.
Maybe,
who knows?
Uh,
a good idea gone terribly,
terribly bad.